[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily a
prosecutor walks back claims that he's
being threatened so should a man
convicted of murdering his wife be
granted parole law enforcement announced
security measures for the trial of derek
chovin in the death of george floyd and
the alleged widower thomas randolph is
back in court waiting for a new trial
for the murder of his sixth wife an
appeals court tosses a conviction for
girlfriend crystal kenny in the murder
of mother kelsea buretta plus a former
nfl player convicted of rape enters a
new plea to meyer along with terry
austin kim kardashian is filing for
divorce from kanye west terry explains
what this court filing means
you know the divorce papers sound
amicable to me kim is asking for joint
legal and joint physical custody and
what that means is they will share the
major decisions affecting the lives of
their children the joint physical
probably means that she will have
physical custody but he'll be able to be
with the children on a regular and
probably consistent basis so i'm hoping
that they'll be able to work it all out
you know for the benefit of the children
brian so that makes sense for the
children terry but other than a new
kanye west album what should we be
expecting from this divorce i mean they
both came into it with a lot what's
separating this six and a half year
marriage going to look like
well that's right they did both come
into the marriage with a lot and
whatever they came into the marriage
with presumably they'll be able to leave
the marriage with anything that they
acquired once they got together in this
marriage they will probably split that
proceeds and so hopefully we won't see
too much arguing i think both parties
make a lot of money so i don't think
either one will be paying alimony to the
other so we'll see what happens but
again i am hoping that this is amicable
yeah of course especially considering
they have four children together at
terry thanks for that update
a prosecutor backpedals on his belief
that a murderer threatened his life and
the life of his family but the change
only came after long crime daily's
angenette levy started looking into the
story here she is to explain
since 2002 los angeles deputy district
attorney john lewin has said that a man
he put in prison for murder should not
be released because he threatened to
kill him and his family well now after
we've shared some documents with lewin
he admits that the threats likely didn't
happen lewin successfully prosecuted
william bradford in 2002 for the 1988
murder of his wife joan until then the
case had gone cold he was really
bothered that even though he had done
the murder he did not think that we had
enough evidence to to convict him
so he was kind of a process oriented guy
the parole board recently said bradford
who's now 87 should be released lewin
objected to that and objected to his
release in 2018 as well
that time governor newsom reversed the
parole board's decision but defense
attorney maya emmeg shared documents
with us showing the inmate who claimed
bradford threatened to kill lewin and
his family took a third polygraph test
back in 2003 that inmate was found to be
truthful when he said he didn't hear
bradford threaten lewin's life three
months later he recanted and he told the
investigator involved in this matter
actually i i did not hear any specific
threats
from
um mr bradford john lewin says since
2002 he's been under the mistaken belief
that that inmate actually passed the
polygraph test when he said that the
threats were made lewin has now written
a second letter to governor newsom
saying that those threats cannot be the
reason to keep bradford in prison lewin
told me on the phone i am an ethical
prosecutor if something's wrong i will
fix it for law and crime daily i'm
angelette levy
terry thank you
let's jump in real quick but let's thank
angenet for digging into this
what is going to be the effect of this
letter because literally prosecutor is
pulling back i think the strongest
argument that could have kept bradford
in
yeah i think the letter is definitely
going to help bradford's case because
lauren was the main person who was
objecting to his release and if the
objection is withdrawn i do think that
the parole board is going to be left
with just considering whether bradford
is a threat to society and i don't think
he is considering his age yeah you look
at his age you remove the threat this
looks like he is going to get released
for the next i don't know they say he
was a year to live to be with his family
thanks terry
turning now to minnesota where jury
selection for the first ex-cop charged
with murdering george floyd is set to
begin in weeks but law enforcement says
they're already planning security
measures
derek chopin's trial is set to begin on
march 8th officials announce operation
safety net which they say will be a
unified command for local police the
sheriff's office state patrol as well as
the national guard planning for the
trial began last summer
efforts ramped up a month ago and the
state's department of public safety says
we're already in phase one
phase two is when jury selection in the
actual trial begins
phase three is when closing arguments
commence and the jury begins their
deliberations which will result in a
verdict
and then phase four being demobilization
and a reduction in staffing and you can
see phase three in the interest of full
disclosure and transparency for the
community phase three is when you will
see the bulk of the resources being
deployed it doesn't mean that there
won't be resources present during phase
two and certainly during phase four but
phase three is when they will see the
full deployment of law enforcement and
the national guard
here to analyze operation safety net is
retired nypd detective and professor at
new york law school professor kirk
burkhalter and terry austin professor
when you worked in the nypd they must
have been high profile cases such as
this what's minneapolis going to look
like the day of the trial
well minneapolis will look very much
like
a mini version of what we saw in
washington dc during the inauguration
and certainly because of the
events that occurred in the capital uh
on the sixth even though law enforcement
was aware of some intelligence
information you know no law enforcement
agency wants to see a repeat of that so
you can expect to see tons of resources
just like the police official just
mentioned uh multiple
agencies the national guard and so forth
and that's geared towards protecting
everyone's rights and protecting
property and not letting things get too
far out of hand um there so you can
expect to see a massive police presence
more than you've ever seen in that city
yeah massive police presence is probably
the right word to use there especially
as you said after january 6 terry the
death of george floyd sparked a global
movement what do you think the trial of
derek shovin will do to the nation
you know this is a very important case
the whole world is watching and we know
that we have a leak here that he was
going children was going to actually
plead guilty to third degree murder and
i think that's going to affect the trial
or at least it will affect how the world
is looking at this trial third degree
murder means a depraved mind and he's
acting without regard to life and i
think if he was willing to plead that he
could very well be convicted of that and
i think
that would make society happy and that
could be a big sentence up to 25 years
so hopefully i think we will see a
conviction here and maybe even a plea at
the end of the day and that leaked plea
deal is going to be something that's
going to come up during jury selection
as to whether or not potential jurors
know about it of course law and crime
will be there giving you the updates as
to the george floyd derrick chopin case
thanks for the update guys still ahead
on law and crime daily the attorney
general of south dakota now facing
charges in a fatal crash just not the
one you're thinking but first married
six times four wives die under
suspicious circumstances
[Music]
and now to the so-called black widower
accused of murdering his sixth wife he
was in court this week angina levy is
back with the latest on thomas
randolph's case and the new series about
it
prosecutors claim that thomas randolph
hired a hitman named mike miller back in
2008 to kill his sixth wife sharon but
then the prosecutors say that randolph
ended up killing both of them mr
randolph can you hear me
yes ma'am
we didn't see randolph during the brief
hearing in clark county but he appeared
via a video link from prison his
attorneys are still working to get all
of the evidence that prosecutors plan to
use against him at trial i
went out picked up six banker boxes out
in mesquite where the appellate council
was
but we are also to make sure that we
have everything we've sent over a hard
drive to mr stanton's office to get a
full copy to make sure there's nothing
missing randolph is getting a new trial
for the deaths of sharon and mike miller
after the nevada supreme court found
prosecutors improperly used information
about the death of one of randolph's
other wives at trial randolph was found
not guilty in that case
am i beautiful
i've done a lot of things i shouldn't
have done i'm not no sane dateline nbc
has a three-part series out about
randolph's case the producers have
followed it since 2008 and they explore
that basic question is randolph innocent
and unlucky or is he a sociopath four of
his six wives have died
do you want the names of my fiances too
randolph remains in prison in nevada
until the start of his second trial a
date for that could be set at another
hearing on march 19th if convicted
randolph faces the possibility of the
death penalty
i'm angelette levy for law and crime
daily
thanks angenet an idaho woman who pled
guilty to helping her boyfriend dispose
of his fiancee's body is getting a
second shot at her sentence chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
has the colorado appeals court decision
new developments in a case overnight
involving the murder of a colorado
flight instructor kelsey barrett who
went missing on thanksgiving day so it
turned out that her fiance patrick
frazee killed her he was found guilty of
first-degree murder based in large part
on the testimony of his girlfriend he
had a fiance and a girlfriend his
girlfriend was also involved in the case
the judge gave her a three-year sentence
but crystal apparently says she was not
advised of her blakely rights which
indicated how the sentence could be
aggravated because of certain conditions
this defendant was charged with a class
six felony so in colorado the
presumptive sentence is up to 18 months
but what the judge did was the judge
found aggravating circumstances and
increased that sentence up to three
years well there's this supreme court
case called bleakly and essentially what
it says is that if a defendant is going
to receive a sentence that is above the
presumptive range then
based on certain facts then a jury must
find those facts beyond a reasonable
doubt it's not something the judge can
just you know eyeball and say oh this
case is particularly egregious
certainly crystal kenny's uh testimony
was important in convicting patrick
frazee according to prosecutors they say
they made a deal with the devil
back with us discuss second sentencing
is professor kirk burkhalter and terry
austin terry seems that the first judge
i don't know just slipped up but this
just means you've got to do it a second
time right
well you know it should have been done
right the first time we hear judges over
and over informing defendants of his or
her rights and it's important it may
seem like it's pro-forma but it's due
process and if in fact the judge did not
inform this defendant of her rights as
it relates to these aggregated factors
and the fact that it could have been
before a jury versus the judge then i do
think that this is a legitimate ground
to you know make a difference in this
case and here we see that it has
now kirk maybe i'm a little too high on
my public defenders soapbox but i get it
some people are going to say this is a
minor technicality but whether you're
protesting and exercising your first
amendment rights open carrying with your
second amendment rights or taking a plea
isn't it these technicalities that
uphold the constitution at the end of
the day
well they certainly uphold the
constitution and i think terry hit the
nail on the head when she mentioned this
was about due process so it's far more
than just a technicality in this country
we don't just put people away
without um circumventing by
circumventing certain rights the right
to a
trial by jury
people are presumed innocent until
convicted of every element of the crime
if someone's going to surrender those
rights they need to be fully informed
and we see this all throughout the law
miranda warnings everybody can mention
you have the right to remain silent and
so forth so that's a cornerstone of our
constitutional laws a cornerstone of of
our criminal law that people must be
informed of their rights if they're
going to surrender those rights and the
result of surrendering those rights
results in some form of loss of liberty
loss of freedom cornerstone professor i
think that's the perfect word for it
right there it's a cornerstone
cornerstone of our constitution
coming up on law and crime daily a trial
delayed for a wisconsin man accused of
murdering his wife why a new judge will
be taking over the case plus a deeper
dive into the death penalty case of a
florida man convicted in the brutal rape
and murder of an eight-year-old girl
after the break
[Music]
we're back the nobody murder trial we're
following at the law and crime network
has been delayed and will now have a new
judge
james prokapovic is on trial for
first-degree intentional homicide he's
accused of killing his wife of 24 years
victoria procopovich she was reported
missing on april 25 2013 and her remains
are yet to be recovered investigators
say it was part of his plan to be with
his new girlfriend day four the trial
was delayed after the judge broke his
ankle the presiding judge will be
replaced with a new judge and the
testimony will restart on monday
the south dakota attorney general
accused of fatally hitting a man with
his vehicle is now facing three
misdemeanor charges
robsburg initially said he thought he
hit a deer last september but found a
human body when he went to check the
scene the next day
fifty-five-year-old joseph bowever was
found deceased
a state highway patrol report says
roundsburg was distracted while driving
brownsburg is charged with operating a
motor vehicle while using a mobile
device driving outside a lane and
careless driving what he's not facing
any felony charges
a florida man is now on death row for
the horrific murder of a little girl
long crimes jesse weber has the latest
on donald smith's appeal
hey brian it's one of the worst stories
we've ever covered on the network and
now we're focusing on it on prime crime
it's every parent's worst nightmare an
eight-year-old girl named cherish
periwinkle is abducted from a store and
what unfolds is absolutely horrifying
we're going to take a look back at the
surveillance footage from the store then
we're going to get into the really
heartbreaking testimony from court and
we're even going to listen to secret
jailhouse recordings between the
defendant and his mom
and we're also going to analyze whether
or not this convicted killer could get a
new trial tune in to law and crime
tragic does not begin to even express
that story thanks jesse new episodes of
prime crime airs fridays at 5 30 p.m
eastern on the lawn crime network
when we come back a former nfl player
convicted of rape is back in court his
new plea deal after the break
welcome back as we move down the
california coast of san diego a former
pro football player has changed his
guilty plea in a sexual assault case
kellen winslow jr was convicted or
admitted guilt to sex crimes against
five women the tight end was found
guilty at trial of raping one woman
exposing himself to another and lewd
conduct to a third the jury was hung on
charges related to two more women
winslow later pled guilty to avoid a
second trial his sentencing hearing has
been pushed back several times due to
the pandemic
now he's changing his plea for jane doe
one a 55 year old hitchhiker
did it hurt when he penetrated you
vaginally with his penis yes i kept on
saying ow ow ow
because i don't know how you fit that
thing in there did he
push upon you or did he just push his
body against you he had his body against
me but he had his hand like on my back
was he basically mounting you in the
front passenger seat of the vehicle
he was on top right he was on top of me
there's going to be a withdrawal of the
guilty plea that was entered on november
4th of 2019
a sexual battery count involving jane
doe won in its place uh mr winslow will
be admitting
a guilty plea
to
assault with the intent to commit rape
the people and the defense have agreed
to a stipulated term in prison of uh for
14 years i want to ask a question
okay go ahead
that's fine
i just wanted to know if i was to go to
trial would i get an actual jury of my
peers that
uh
uh people of color that would look like
me when i get a try a jury trial like
that
okay
yeah mr winslow the the uh point now is
the change of plea form that you already
executed
is uh
is a binding change of plea form uh you
cannot get to another trial unless you
make a motion to withdraw your plea of
guilty uh do you give up those
constitutional rights at this point
yes i do
back to discuss winslow's new plea deal
is professor kirk burkhalter and terry
austin now i want to ask you both the
the same question and whether or not you
agree with the plea but first the
details the old plea was a range of 12
to 18 years so parole could release him
at 12 years or later the new plea deal
straight 14 years old plea deal included
didn't include jane doe one new plea
deal includes her with a violent offense
charge it looks like there were some
concessions on both sides avoiding the
risk of a new trial and having the
victims testify again so is this justice
professor
well i believe so and certainly the uh
prosecutor would not have agreed to the
plea i would would think without talking
to the victims and
ensuring that they were interested and
agreed to the plea deal it certainly
saves them
the pain of having to testify throughout
this trial and sit through the other
trial for the defendant it splits the
difference between the 12 and the 18
for the testimony was devastating uh in
the first trial against him so uh quite
often defendants just want to get on and
start serving their sentence so for all
parties considered it probably is
justice
yeah i mean terry he gets a determinate
time meaning he knows 14 years he comes
out and jane doane number one is
probably going to be really happy about
this plea deal what do you think
you know i agree with kurt here i do
think there's justice here if you
remember jane doe number one the jury
was deadlocked on all three counts the
felony kidnapping the rape and the oral
copulation it was seven to five so
there's a risk here that in fact winslow
might lose out on that if he doesn't
include this in the deal and obviously
to have her have to testify again would
be very difficult so i think this is
justice i think it's a win-win for both
sides and i think
very much so that justice has been done
in this case yeah and this is what i can
tell you as a public defender you do
from the beginning of your case even
after a trial you're still negotiating
moving pieces around seeing if you can
get a better deal for your client that
seems to have happened here kirk terry
thank you and thank you for joining us
here at long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you